I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the dokudokunomi the poison
food which turns its user into a Venom
human one of the deadliest powers in the
entire series it was eaten by Magellan
the former Warden of impel down this
route allows you to produce a huge
variety of poison that can knock out or
kill anyone plus it can affect a large
number of enemies at the same time so a
perfect 25 out of 25 points also
poisonous defense is equally legendary
since you can coat your entire body and
poison anyone who touches you will be in
serious trouble 23 points and for
special abilities you automatically
become immune to all poisons a perfectly
healthy 20 points and it's also quite
practical in real life since you can
make venom roads to travel anywhere
super quickly 10 points here however one
major weakness is that if you aren't
careful you can easily poison your
friends or if you eat your tasty poison
you will become very familiar with the
toilet mine is a toxic 12 points
bringing its total to 66 points and a
third place on the podium for now